we got the story from the post
millennial breaking 2018 letter States
Michael Cohen paid Stormy Daniels with
his own funds Trump did not reimburse oh
geez I wonder why it is that when the
story first broke years ago they did not
move to indict Trump could it be that he
didn't have anything to do with it a
2010 letter from former Trump lawyer
Michael Cohen's team to officials at the
Federal Election Commission has revealed
that the then president that the then
president was not involved in the
payment of alleged hush money to Stormy
Daniels the letter obtained by The Daily
Mail stated that it was Cohen who paid
Daniel's a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars out of his own pocket quote in a
private transaction in 2016 before the
U.S presidential election Mr Cohen used
his own personal funds to facilitate a
payment of 130 000 to Ms Stephanie
Clifford neither the Trump organization
nor the Trump campaign was a party to
the transaction with Miss Clifford and
neither reimbursed Mr Cohen in the
payment directly or indirectly Cohen's
team went on to explain that neither Mr
Cohen nor essential Consultants LLC made
any in-kind contributions to Trump for
president or any other presidential
campaign committee nor was coin a
government employee at the time thus
they argued the payment in question does
not constitute a campaign contribution
or expenditure and therefore the FEC
lacks jurisdiction over this matter
well that's it there goes story there it
goes you can't indict him I mean this is
crazy this is crazy where is our country
going if you're indicting a leading
candidate for president on something
which by the way this happened how long
ago like are we living in the past this
didn't happen recently this letter is
from 2018. so here we have the actual
letter right here you can see it from
Daily Mail
it says uh McDermott will and Emery
February 8 2018 to the FEC so the
question is did this individual Stephen
M Ryan counsel for Michael Cohen lie to
the FEC likely not it's more likely that
it's been a Witch Hunt the whole time
Democrats have been weaponizing the
justice system to go after Donald Trump
with lies and smears and this proves
that it's all bunk nonsense yeah and I
would say Cohen wants payback because
Cohen went to jail which was really his
own fault he went to jail and he blames
Trump and he didn't get a new job didn't
get money with Trump and so he turned
into an anti-trump guy and this was part
of his scheme to be able to grow his
star on the left being the guy who took
down Trump so he's willing to lie like
Cheney like kenzinger the uh like uh was
it Joe Walsh yep these people know what
they're doing they they they're you know
what I think it is people let go and go
to prison and then you'll see people
like you know Joe Walsh or whatever and
they're like I I know who Butters my
bread I better just fall in line with
the Deep state
100 why would Cohen pay Stormy Daniels
130 000 anyway
that part never made sense to me I mean
I think it makes sense it's just it's a
question of personal issues that we're
not privy to right yeah is it possible
that he's just super rich and it's like
130 Grands not much to take the pressure
off Donald Trump I'm just going to do it
for him kind of thing maybe it could be
this
Michael Cohen was he was the council for
Trump right he was he was a lawyer for
Trump yeah imagine you're a lawyer for a
client and the client says listen I need
you to take care of these extraneous
things I'm not going to waste time with
them right I'm busy with my campaign and
then Michael Cohen's thinking this
Stormy Daniels lady is causing me a
headache it's my job to deal with it but
she won't shut up and go away I got it
I'll pay her off
that will make my job so much easier now
Donald Trump in this scenario this
hypothetical Donald Trump doesn't go to
Michael Cohen and say pay her off make
her shut up Donald Trump says you know I
don't know what this is all about figure
out what's going on I'm gonna get back
to work you deal with it and then
Michael Cohen says instead of doing my
job filing paperwork and having to deal
with this it's easier for me to just pay
for her to go away personally and then
just bill the hours to Trump the Trump
campaign likely then says I have no idea
what this is here's here's you know
Michael Cohen here this makes sense
imagine that's what happened
they're they're claiming Trump
paid the money to start McDonald's and
called it legal fees it's entirely
possible Michael Cohen according to this
letter did it himself and then without
Trump's knowledge build Trump for the
payment he made to Stormy Daniels and
Trump was just like I guess we owe legal
fees and so that's the 35 000 that Trump
paid well Trump paid Michael Cohen
thirty five thousand dollars a year
later in October of 2017. there's a
check from Trump to Cohen for 35 Grand
sure and that could be anything though
man when I get a legal bill I don't I
tip it for my for the company like we
get legal bills because of all the legal
work that we do like I gotta call lawyer
like we're gonna file this we're going
to file that you know new company old
company copyright I don't go through
this whole itinerary I call the lawyer
and say here's what we need done I need
this song cup you know trademark I need
this thing trademarked we're launching
an LLC for here get it done send me the
invoice they send me an invoice I click
pay yep the thing is though if I had a
lawyer and and I owed and I wanted and
they just went and gave someone a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars that
would be the most insane you would
suggest yes
I I explained that already
if I go to a lawyer and say I need four
five new companies formed in the state
of Delaware and I need it done by next
week he goes okay I got it gets off the
phone and then starts sweating being
like how am I gonna get five filings
done in a week so he calls his buddy at
the at the office and says listen just
shove it under the door I'll give you a
couple hundred bucks don't tell anybody
I need to get this done that's not my
fault if that person does that I didn't
tell them to break the law I'm just
saying hypothetically it's it's the
possible I think the simple solution to
this is considering this letter unless
unless you think Michael Cohen committed
more felonies with his legal team lying
to the FEC which I think is less likely
that that's a bigger conspiracy I
suppose what makes sense is Trump's got
a lawyer and he's like I don't hang out
the lawyer I don't know how the lawyer
does all I know is if he's like I get an
email I send it to him I say you deal
with it yeah it's like won't somebody
rid me of this priest and then Cohen's
like I got you buddy I could see it no
no but you misunderstand I'm saying when
I talk to my lawyer I don't tell them
what to do or say won't someone read me
of this priest I say you tell me what
you think needs to be done you're my
lawyer I'm calling you for advice send
me the bill Michael Cohen then decided
to take this action of his own volition
because it was easier than actually
doing his job
his job of negotiating a settlement or
whatever his job may be maybe he was
like if this book comes out I'm going to
be drowning in legal paperwork Trump's
going to sue her and then I'm gonna have
to deal with that it's easier if I just
pay her and don't tell anybody I mean
whatever the case there's I'm looking at
that there's very little and no evidence
that Trump paid Stormy Daniels anything
is that true yes
and by the way remember stormy said that
they never had sex
everybody forgets this she said that
back then yeah she just lied or
something so we have on both sides of
this Cohen and stormy both have a
history of either lying or telling the
truth in different scenarios because
they've said both things or speaking out
both sides their mouths so we know that
they're lying so these are proven liars
and in Michael's case it sent him to
prison so we're supposed to take the
words of these people no serious
prosecutor would take somebody like this
and go oh I'm gonna make this the Crux
of my case to take down a former
president of the United States that's
ludicrous and beyond that you know I
think Tim's exactly right I can see it
now in in the trumpian way he's in there
with Cohen Cohen starts to bring
something he goes look look Michael I
just want you to take care of everything
I got the greatest campaign going on
right now the greatest campaign I gotta
deal with that you take care of
everything else okay the checkbook's
over there and that's it you know and
imagine this Michael Cohen thinking if
stormy does this book
I am going to lose a client because it's
gonna Trump's campaign could be ruined
like there's so many reasons why Michael
Cohen would have done this of his own
volition thinking like Trump pays me x
amount a million dollars or whatever as
his lawyer I get all these great
billable hours I can't let this stormy
lady ruin that for me I'll just pay her
off and won't tell anybody and now
they're trying to use that against Trump
who presumably had not well literally
according to this letter had nothing to
do with it with protecting Prestige too
because the idea for Cohen was if Trump
does pull this off and win I'm gonna get
some prestigious job I'm gonna get to go
to the White House with him I'm going to
be an even more important person and you
have to go into the psychology of a guy
like that and the way he grew up and
everything it doesn't seem like he had
the most you know sort of like uh
you know privileged background he worked
his way up to where he was and wanted to
get to the next level and continue to
impress the person he married and things
like that because she's a crazy lib by
the way
um but the White House would offer that
ability you know in his mind and that
could all be taken from him too I think
that all plays into it honestly your
theory makes a lot of sense considering
this letter I think that seems to be the
most likely outcome not that I know for
sure anything like that but then one day
you know Cohen then says you know what
I'll do I'll pay her off and then build
Trump as a legal fee and he won't even
know what it's for and he's a
billionaire he probably just gets the
bill and then says you know whatever pay
Cohen I don't know he's the lawyer doing
the job regardless of the scenario
there's no evidence that Trump knew of
any of this like there's no you can't
take him down for something that kohen
did
yeah there's no there's no intention you
know there's no exchange of him knowing
that this was this Exchange took place I
don't I really don't like plausible
deniability where it's obvious that you
told someone to do something for you but
there's no paper trail I can't stand
that because that's the the seed of
corruption but at the same time there's
no evidence that he told him to do it
right
so Alvin Bragg osoros D.A is just
lighting fire to this country
for what I think it may not be about
Trump so this is a Soros D.A so much of
what we've seen from them has been DC
comic book villny released the inmates
from Arkham Asylum they're doing it all
across the country this may be more
indict the president by any means
necessary to rip this country apart yep
light a fire Watch What Happens watch
everything burn I definitely fall in
line with that I mean I wrote a story I
was warning people about these Soros
prosecutors probably about five six
years ago I wrote a couple major pieces
one in New York post about how Soros was
using DA's to tear apart the fabric of
America and it totally makes sense if
you think about and you look at the
micro level on what these DA's are doing
to these cities and changing just the
window of acceptability that people have
about what they're willing to put up
with and what is normalized and what is
criminalized suddenly suddenly violent
crime is no longer important suddenly
violent speech is important okay and
what they frame is violent speech
becomes important and wrong ideas become
more and more dangerous but actually
going and breaking into somebody's house
with their car no that's no big deal
that's just to be expected if you live
in one of these hell holes and I think
that the reality that we're seeing play
out here is these people keep amping it
up time after time and time again and
this guy's just taking it to the next
natural level which is to start the
biggest fire they've started yet yep
that's why people are saying why would
he try to indict Trump on this because
this isn't what matters the indictment
is what matters I've that's why I have a
feeling I'm like okay so he he was
supposed to get indicted yesterday then
it was today now it's not happening this
week apparently but I got a feeling this
dude's gonna do whatever he can to just
file it so that it hits the Press it's
going to enrage Trump supporters it's
going to cause you know these woke Libs
to be like screaming it will be lighting
a fire on this uh lighting this country
on fire yeah and there's actually DC
Consultants that truly believe this is
going to hurt Trump okay I live in
Tennessee
and I can tell you this is not going to
hurt Trump okay the people who are on
the fence because maybe they were upset
about the vaccine or maybe they were
upset that j6 people were not given a
pardon before he left the non-violent
ones or maybe they were upset that he
gave the presidential Commendation Medal
to fauci whatever the reason whatever
the reason was they were upset okay
um even a lot of those people are going
oh no this is a line we can't cross in
America this is something we cannot
accept and we're not going to accept
political prosecutions you know what
Trump's my guy now because he's the one
that's going to have to take this on
because they're personally going after
him and he's going to make it personal
and we need somebody who's going to make
it personal and be a fighter against
this and I think they're going to be
really really in for a surprise when
they see how the poll numbers continue
to turn toward him if they do this yeah
we're in the in a kind of a culture of
victimhood where victimhood makes you
powerful so I don't understand why they
don't realize that victimizing Trump is
going to make them more powerful or seem
more powerful he's like really himself
to the corner of the internet on his own
social network barely anyone hears from
him he's it's like radio sounds people
are talking about DeSantis and yet this
liberal media company these people are
still bringing him into the spotlight
the same dumb thing they did in 2016 and
got him elected Hillary Clinton got him
elected because all she did was talk
about him there's some people who think
that this is also intentional to boost
him because they would rather face him
in a general I tend to disagree with
that I think that they're genuinely
still so hung up on Trump and they're
still so incensed by him and they're
still so fearful of the idea of populism
rising in America that they're willing
to do anything to take him down because
of the idea he represents and I think
that's what they really fear you know
and we'll see we'll see how it plays out
here but I really think just like Tim
they're going to indict him I think that
there's no question they're going to do
that and if it's not this they're going
to do it in Georgia with the Georgia
case but there's a couple different
prosecutors all far left who have this
as basically the Crux of their campaign
was going after Trump one of them if not
multiple and I tend to think it's going
to be multiple are going to drop
indictments on him and I've been saying
that for a long time I Know Jack besobic
has I think you did too before on a show
like six months or a year maybe even a
year ago you said you thought they would
indict him oh yeah and so this is
something it was not a secret we all
kind of saw this coming that if you
elect crazy people like this who
campaign on this one or two of them is
going to go and actually do it and
that's where we're at and they'll make
up whatever reason it doesn't need to be
they don't need a reason in fact it's
better that it's this when we're talking
about the Fire Starting method that
they're kind of going after and causing
division than it is that it was a
blatant murder on camera because that
wouldn't cause the type of division they
seek to to to cause you know and that's
that's Marxism at its core you know
dividing people has to happen because
you've never seen Marxism or leftism
thrive in a happy country it only comes
to be in chaos so you have to create
chaos you know it's why it's why these
antifa people look like they're out of a
Batman movie and you pull them out of a
mental and uh you know a mental
institution and the Jokers brought him
out and it's like hey you guys are going
to work let's go do this because if you
look like every time I see that Andy no
post where he's got like 40 antifa
people in a lineup they look like
they're out of Arkham Asylum every
single time every time it's our eyes all
up in that and after all God knows what
psychotropics they're they're on legally
and and the funny thing is we're living
in a comic book story man Trump is this
billionaire who who runs for president
to try and fix the problem and fight
back against a globalist elite you know
and all that stuff and then you got the
villains are literally getting elected
with with an evil Billionaire's money
and then releasing the criminals imagine
if you opened a Batman comic no no let's
just say a Justice League comic and
Batman is meeting with Superman Superman
walks in and he's like the alarms are
all going off in the Watchtower it's a
man's like Batman what's Bruce what's
happening and he goes all over the
United States criminals are being
released from their prisons how it's
Luther he he used his vast wealth to get
a bunch of District Attorneys into Power
who then started releasing criminals on
the streets wreaking chaos and then the
the conflict of the story is like how do
you get these criminals back in jail
when it was done through a legal process
this is why I always liked Lex Luthor as
a villain because he had the arc where
he is a legitimate businessman I love
the arc where he runs for president does
it legitimately and Superman can't touch
him that's what we're seeing with these
Soros DA's with the left politicians
going after Trump in this way
releasing the criminals is as comic book
villain as it gets
and we all know what's happening I mean
come on I want to know who are we in the
comic book you know that's that's an
interesting question but beyond that you
know when you look at this one of the
real problems is the weakness of the
institutions on the right and the the
you know we'll call it the the
Republican party in general but it's
really sort of the Old Guard Republicans
because they can't say they weren't
warned they had people warning them this
was going to happen and they didn't even
try to fight it they didn't even try to
stop it they didn't try to put up some
independent and fund them really well in
these Races they didn't try anything to
try to stop these sorosdas they just
sort of thought hey they sound crazy
they're saying crazy stuff that helps us
because we can cut ads to them saying
crazy stuff and the truth is no we're
not living in that world anymore guys
you let Communists into power and you
let them destroy a country we're not
talking about the ads for your next
cycle because they said some crazy thing
we were talking about this with Troy
Nails yesterday he's a good dude and I
feel a little bad because it was more
like me getting angry and then kind of
just yelling because I'm like instead of
looking at what Democrats do to win it's
just this defeatist mentality about the
2020 election being stolen and then
that's when I brought up you and I'm
like uh uh you know I think it was Phil
Levante who was on the show and he
mentions Ronald McDaniel winning with
harmy Dillon running for for RNC chair
some real change after all this failure
and defeat they just keep doing the same
thing and then I'm like look at what the
RNC does to Robbie Starbuck he's like
this this up and coming very prominent
he's younger everybody's super like into
him handsome handsome you know and
they're like oh very tough absolutely
strong
should be a new voice in Congress and
the Republican Party removed you what
happened with that what exactly happened
they decided that they wanted somebody
else and this is I mean this sounds so
crazy to people they can't believe it
because I've never heard of it happening
before like I didn't even know this was
a thing that was possible you can go run
a race for over a year you can win over
the hearts and minds of people you you
can be just killing everybody in the
polls and all of a sudden some people
can get together
well we've decided we don't want you to
be the standard bearer of our party we
think that could not be a good thing for
us so we're going to go ahead and choose
somebody else so you can't be on the
ballot it's like I thought I lived in
America where people get to vote and
decide who they want I went out there we
knocked more doors we called more people
I did more events I worked my tail off
other people didn't they hid in their
houses okay and they worked this machine
behind the scenes to get the support of
party bosses and then they go what's in
the bylaws what secret rules can we pull
out that people have no clue about and
use that to get rid of somebody who we
consider dangerous and I'll tell you
this personally I personally think a big
reason why what happened to me happened
was because I spoke out so forcefully
against big pharmaceutical companies and
because everything was okay until that
point but when I started to go after
them over what was happening throughout
this entire past few years and I started
to really delve into how they were
profiting on the backs of American
people and on sickness and going into
how we really need to look at changing
things because it's the reason why so
many young people go over and get
attracted by socialism and the ideas of
health care for all and things like that
because we do have a sick care system
not a Health Care system and it's broken
and we allow these big pharmaceutical
companies to start right away you know
if you're a kid on Tick Tock you're
getting ads already for what medication
you need because you have anxiety you
know they're already pushing this stuff
from the earliest stage they can on
everybody and we've allowed it for so
long and that is when they really
started to get angry at me is when I
wouldn't let go about reforming some of
these policies around big pharmaceutical
companies I think it was before that it
might have been it might have been but I
think there's an adult Paradigm a good
old boy system that is very much kissed
the ring you know you play along to get
along you just do things a certain way
but that old Paradigm doesn't work
there's a new right of activists and we
won't we'll won't survive not just as a
party but as you know uh you know our
values everything if we don't raise up
activists and Robbie's an activist and
so that doesn't fit in to that old
Paradigm because that system they want
politicians they want you to talk to
them in the back room about the real
stuff but then in front of people or if
you go on a show they want you to have
these perfectly coiffed and I can do
them I could give you guys political
answers all night that like I'm saying
nothing meaning nothing but it's an
answer technically and that's what they
want from their politicians they want
them to say nothing mean nothing I want
people where I know exactly where they
stand I want to know if I hate them I
want to know if I love them I think
that's what people deserve that's what
our Founders did you go back and read
our Founders and I encourage every young
person who's listening go back and read
their writings if you've never had these
people were brilliant writers and you
have to keep in mind when you read these
most of these people did not go to
school they taught themselves how to
write they taught themselves The Art of
language and you read their writing it
is the most brilliant it stands every
test of time I mean they could literally
write about you going to the bathroom in
a lake and it would sound Exquisite okay
I don't know how they they did this but
they pulled it off read this and you see
that these were forceful men these were
men who had convictions they stood for
something they were willing to die for
it where are those people today where
are our Rebels where are the people who
are Rebel with a cause not just somebody
who's like you know hooked on drugs and
do stupid things somebody with a cause
who says I am willing to go all the way
I'm willing to die from what I believe
in because it is so important we had
those men once and it's the reason we're
all sitting here but not having those
men is the reason why our children will
not have the same opportunity unless we
we actually fix it raise up a generation
of activists Jeffrey witty in the chat
mentioned they were all 24 years old
yeah not all of them I think Benjamin
Franklin was a little bit some of them
were a little older but
yes
imagine being you're like 18 and you own
property and you're like running a farm
with a wife and some like you have a kid
already signed the Constitution
you signed the conversation yeah you
know like told the king screw off try me
yeah that's crazy I mean those people at
boss yeah meanwhile this generation's
like
well look look here's here's the thing
back in the day the founding fathers
they didn't work they didn't eat and so
when the crown is pushing on them and
taking from them they're like listen I
work every day to feed my family and
then you come and you take no more it's
the inverse now these Millennials are
like look every day I wake up and you
provide so I will do whatever you say
yep remind me again too when we talk
about like the Boston Tea Party the tax
raise at the time it was equivalent to
like
not even not even two percent I think
somebody could look it up I want to give
people the real number I don't know if
you guys can look it up but it was Tiny
now politicians throw around things all
the time like Biden the other days I
want to add an extra 38 I want to add
this I want to add they want to tax
everything these guys were willing to
die for what was it
was it was a protest of the Tea Act
and uh to undercut the price of illegal
tea smuggling to the British colonies
basically it was going to make it so
that they had to pay more for tea that
came from the East India trading company
but it was like the the
today like less than two percent hike in
the cost was it just like the final
straw of a bunch of things that have
been building and building the actors
granted the company the right to
directly ship its tea to North America
and the right to the duty-free export of
tea from Britain although the tax
imposed by the Townshend Acts and
collected in the colonies remained in
force it received Royal Ascent so I
don't think it was specifically about uh
taxes I think it was about I mean it was
about taxes but it was about uh what is
it the toggle passing on the cost eighty
six percent of all Team America was
smuggled Dutch tea right so all of a
sudden the cost of tea was going to
Skyrocket because they were like no you
now have to buy from this company
because they're beleaguered and they
need your sales yeah or they need your
purchases and the Skyrocket again is
like around it what would be equivalent
to today like a two percent hike you
know in your overall cost
today you know they could propose a 50
extra tax on us and people just go along
with their day and they're happy to
scroll the phone and like no big deal
back then they were like no two percent
were gonna go die for this okay so we'll
burn the ships I'm sorry the Townshend
Acts was a series of taxes and
regulations to fund the administration
of the British British colonies in
America and that was a tax hike that
pissed everybody off because then T
became ridiculous ridiculously expensive
what year was that indirect tax on glass
LEDs paints paper and tea all of which
had to be imported from Britain then
when they were told you now have to buy
the East India company's team you can't
smuggle it anymore it's like well now
T's expensive yeah through it in the
harbor and and what we got going on
today is inflation which is causing the
price of goods to go up because of the
supply chain problems on all other
reasons and uh so we can't blame them
for taxing us even though they've caused
the cost to go up we can
we absolutely can blame them yes yeah
look at the Federal Reserve I blame them
for all of it I think Tim and I are on
like the same monetary train and we
don't have enough people in Congress who
are on the same train like I think that
the vast majority of taxes out there are
blatantly criminal they're blatantly
criminal we need a flat tax if anything
that is just very easy very fair get rid
of the IRS just have a flat tax I I
don't know if I'm on board with a flat
tax necessarily I'm more I'm closer to
Steve Bannon on this one but not as far
as he goes because Bennett wants a
wealth tax and I'm like I'm not for that
but you know bannon's position is the
wealthy Elites are ripping us off and
they're they're rigging the game and if
in their favor and I'm like it's very
populist of you I mean it's like an
Occupy Wall Street position he's like
well it's true and so he's like I'm all
for the wax Tech uh well wax texting tax
the attacks the bikini waxes tax all
these billionaires and take everything
from them and I'm like okay well I don't
go that far but I'm I'm somewhere in the
middle I guess and it's really funny
that bannon's got like a traditional
liberal position on taxation well I
think that's actually that's a lot of
populous and I tend to agree with him
here's the thing that I would tell
conservatives who for a long time
defended not raising taxes on somebody
like Jeff Bezos Jeff Bezos hates you the
billionaire class they hate Republicans
more than anything they hate populist
Republicans they hate all Republicans
okay there's very few exceptions to that
rule there's maybe three or four
billionaires I know who are more
conservative leaning all the rest that
are very publicly well known they're
extremely far left and if they're not
personally they allow their image to be
presented as such because it's
beneficial to them so really they have
no values which in turn to me means
you're a leftist because if you have no
values you stand for nothing you're
allowing everything to happen that's
happening with our culture and Society
being torn to shreds and so I'm not
going to go fight for these people I'm
not gonna go fight for for Jeff Bezos to
be able to keep more money this dude
built his company on a crooked idea that
Amazon if you ranted a loss for long
enough would build up enough of a market
share to kill so many competitors that
you suddenly hold so much market share
that you can raise the prices on
everything anybody can really do
anything because you're such a big
business you're undefeatable at that
point and that's what they've done he
did a great job doing it he worked in
game the system beautifully in terms of
success but he gained the American
people at the same time that was not a
true sort of presentation of capitalism
capitalism doesn't present as hey lose
money for 15 years and then let's see
what happens you know like it's a
perverted system of it and so people
like that I'm not going to fight for him
not have to pay more but for your
regular middle class person absolutely
the the amount we tax people is
ridiculous thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time